- The global economic
outlook for this year
might be less gloomy than
previously predicted,
although that's not the case for the UK.
Britain is the only member
of the group of seven
nations whose economy
is likely to shrink in 2023, according
to the International Monetary
Fund's January forecasts.
The country has been grappling
with a cost of living crisis,
with discontent spilling
out onto the streets
with months of strikes.
- We have told the government
there's an increasing problem.
- While the US and
other nations have begun
to rebound from the pandemic,
the UK has been struggling
to turn the tide.
The UK's flagging economy
now looks set to shrink
by 0.6% this year.
Even being outperformed
by sanctions hit Russia.
Here's why.
Energy prices worldwide soared
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
In the UK, inflation is close
to its highest in 40 years,
largely driven by those high energy costs.
Britain was hit particularly hard
as it relies on natural gas for
much of its power generation
and has limited storage capacity.
Meanwhile, the US was able to
knock down prices domestically
after the government released
record amounts of oil
from its strategic petroleum reserves.
In many countries, for example, the US,
inflation is beginning to ease,
thanks partly to policies
heightening by central banks.
The Federal Reserve hiked interest rates
multiple times last year
in a bid to curb inflation.
It now appears to be paying off.
Consumer spending is starting to falter,
and price increases are easing,
suggesting that the US
economy is slowing down.
The UK central bank, the Bank of England,
also raised interest rates
to try to slow inflation.
Yet UK prices have
continued to rise rapidly.
Grocery prices surged nearly
17%, and the trade association,
the British Retail Consortium,
says prices have yet to peak.
Workers across sectors
have suffered a decline
in inflation-adjusted wages,
especially those whose salaries
are paid for by the state.
Strikes from workers
such as train drivers,
postal workers, nurses and teachers
have become a familiar
sight across the UK.
- (indistinct) The NHS.
- [Nurses] We are the NHS.
- Things continue to
increase, except for our pay.
Our working conditions have not changed.
In fact, they've got worse.
- Another problem for growth
is that the country's employment
rate has yet to recover
to pre-pandemic levels,
unlike most other G7 nations.
The UK is suffering from
a decline in the workforce
with a number of vacancies
close to record levels.
Many have taken early
retirement and Britain's exit
from the EU has put more barriers
in place for workers from the bloc,
meaning gaps aren't able
to be filled as easily.
To compare, in the US
where the unemployment rate
is at a multi-decade low,
the total workforce rose
to a new record in January, however,
there are signs that the
tide could also be turning.
The Bank of England
has moderated its
economic growth forecasts
for the UK, which were
previously very negative.
It thinks that while Britain
is still expected to enter a recession,
that it's likely to be shallower
and shorter than previously feared.
And it says that inflation
is likely to drop sharply this year.
The Bank of England raised
its key interest rate
on February 2nd, but it signaled
that it may pause soon,
meaning the economy
won't have to endure
further sizable increases
in borrowing costs.
- We have seen a turning of the corner
but it's very early days
and the risks are very large
and it's really that that I think shapes
where we go from here.
(pensive music)